[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Megan is
with us Megan is in Louisville Kentucky
Hi Megan welcome to the ramsy show hi
thank you so much for having me I'm in
the parking lot of the dry cleaners I
just picked up my wedding dress awesome
Y how
fun thank you I'm getting married on the
1 of January and I'm so excited should
be
congratulations thank you so much um so
my fiance is amazing he's incredible but
um he's not that great with money which
is why I'm
calling sorry so um we've been together
for a while and um over the course of
the last maybe year um he revealed that
he's in a lot of credit card debt um
about $58,000
worth yeah um so in February of this
year I actually took out a home equity
loan um at prime rate so what is that
8.5 I think well wait a second you said
he's not that great with money you're
taking out helocs what are you taking
out a Helo for yeah I mean I knew where
we were going I knew we were forever and
I knew I wanted to just nip this in the
bud so he cut up his credit card and we
put all of his money um we Consolidated
all of his credit card debt into a helck
and he's been making steady payments
since then to me to pay on that Lord
Jesus okay okay so um he commits to
about $1,000 a month to paying that off
and um we're predicting about a four and
a half year to five year payoff of all
that no no no what do you
make oh I only make $60,000 a year and
he makes 120 okay so you make $180,000
you have $58,000 in debt we are not
waiting six freaking years you're doing
this next
year okay okay we we have made some
mistakes he yeah had a bunch of credit
card debt and was overspending
apparently he has stopped that I hope it
sounds like you made a mistake of
financing someone that you weren't
married to debt you're getting ready to
fix that in about a week thank you God
so you'll be safe at that point and uh
we don't want to spoil the wedding with
too much of this talk but as soon as you
guys get home from the honeymoon now
it's we have $58,000 in debt and we need
to pay that off with our $180,000 income
as fast as we can and that means we
ain't doing nothing till we get this
mess cleaned up do you guys have any
either one of you have any
money yeah so I actually have about
$55,000 in stocks that I got as um bonus
from a job I previously had that I've
never touched so time to touch it after
after you're
married cash that out and pay this
off great okay that's what I was hoping
you were GNA say but I wasn't sure if
that's a wise decision so it's a
wonderfully wise decision now here's the
trick the two of you from uh This Day
Forward are going to lock arms and not
borrow money and be on a budget together
and communicate a lot more about money
than you had
been yes in other words his spending
stays above his
income and the credit cards grow back
because the habits didn't
change then the advice we just gave you
might not have been smart
agreed yes that makes sense did I hear
you say it's a scary topic
yes it's it's a little nerve-wracking to
uh confront his you know weak links you
know the fact that he like spend a lot
of money it's you too because he he did
rack up that credit card debt but listen
it was not a smart choice to roll it
into a HELOC I'm not going to lie about
that so I think you both have something
some things to learn here I think we
should give them Financial Peace
University yeah if we give you the class
will you go through it together so you
got a book to work from I would love for
him to have those resources and for me
to be a part of that as well I think
that would be amazing let me help you
that's not how it works okay he doesn't
need the resources we need to go through
the class together so we are doing this
stuff together not not Dave's going to
school him
up I understand I completely understand
I'm just listening to your verbiage
kiddo so yeah okay you hang on we're GNA
give this too you as a wedding gift and
a Christmas present and since we abused
you right before your wedding I know we
just yelled at her right before the wedd
it's just but she's picking up her
wedding dress calls from the cleaners
and we yell at her so nobody yelled at
her we love her we want her to win true
but we kept I kept telling her she was
just as as well she is she is they both
I won't say the s word they both did
silly things a silly the SW word oh my
gosh they both did stupid things dve
there we go come on on it there we go
it's okay we love her and she's going to
win she she's smart she makes good money
he makes good money if but listen the
thing is what we want for you this is
the number one money and money issues or
the number one stress point in marriage
Megan and you're getting married so we
want you guys to have real clean open
honest dialogue around this both of you
uh we don't want touchy subject we don't
want you you know you're not shaming him
uh we both are looking at this and
saying okay from this point forward
we're not using credit cards from this
point forward we're going to agree on a
budget and we're going to stick to the
budget that we both agreed to it's it's
a marital contract uh from this point
forward we're going to save up and pay
cash for things cuz you're dumping
$60,000 of money that you brought into
the marriage against his
mistakes yeah and so the two of you
together need assurances that the two of
you together are going to move forward
in very clean stuff the old wedding vows
most people know in sickness and in
health for richer for poor and sickness
in health the old wedding vows in the
book of common prayer say unto thee all
my worldly Goods I pledge oo and so that
indicates this Unity this Oneness in the
marriage where we're sharing
everything not your debt my debt not
your checking account my checking
account not your income my income it's
our our hour our hour our when you get
married you are French we we we it's
ours okay that's what you're doing and
there's a Oneness to that and by the way
not only is that a beautiful and
romantic and wonderful Mar thing where
the communication is very high and the
quality of the relationship is very high
the uh interesting part also is the data
tells us from studying millionaires that
it increases the probability of you
becoming wealthy vastly the number of
people that become wealthy while
dragging a misbehaving spouse is almost
zero it's almost zero so this this idea
that you work together it's like we're
going to do this together we're going to
raise kids together when you when you
argue about what how to treat you know
how to make the kids behave the kids are
the only ones that
lose you know and you argue about how to
make the money behave the money loses
you know so getting on that same page is
a big deal and that's not just aimed at
Megan that's aimed at all of you out
there this time of year some of you are
home for Christmas you got a little time
on your hands you need to sit down with
each other and go hey this is what's
going on it this be some confession is
good for the soul time for some of you
some of you got to come clean on
I'm kind of ashamed I've been doing this
and I'm I'm really been doing some stuff
I don't like and I know you're not going
to like it and I don't even want to talk
about it but we're going to talk about
it that's the that you need to do some
of that throughing the holidays some of
you create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life